cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com my show idea and I've
mentioned on the show and I pitch we go
to Antarctica yes we have to do it
everybody's been telling me absolutely
absolutely but my show idea was it takes
place in the last City and the people
who live there call it the last City and
no one really knows why human
civilization collapsed but all other
cities on Earth are Barren empty
wastelands of Decay ruin cars just
falling apart it's like a
post-apocalyptic scene and this city is
has grown to a few million people with
technology somewhat comparable but a
little bit better than ours and they
have Scouts going out doing missions to
expand the territory of the city and
reclaim more farmland and things like
this and then one day they come across
weird tall or you know yeah probably
tall slender beings in like white suits
with like white helmets and they get
into a fight and these Advanced beings
like just energy blast them and then
what happens is these These Guys in
Expedition are like body cam filming it
it's being transmitted back and they're
like these these are aliens or something
and they must be what wiped out human
civilization they've come back to kill
us what what and then it turns out it
was my show idea
spoiler alert if the shower gets made
it'll be run for you uh the the
Revelation is
at some point people started migrating
to the metaverse because you can connect
your brain and eat filet mignon every
night if you want forever you you you
don't live forever but like thousands of
years compared to 70 on Earth yeah well
no but expand time like yet your mind
moves faster or whatever so when you're
when you're plugged into the metaverse
you can virtual reality you can
experience anything you want so there's
literally no reason to leave so they all
end up living in pods underground in
these facilities where in their they
experience life much like ours but in
base reality they never leave the Pod
and so the people who are the last City
don't know what happened because news
never stopped information as to why
humans migrated persists but it
persisted into the metaverse for humans
who are outside of that system and don't
have access to it they don't have the
historical records it just one day
disappeared so you've got mountain
people trailer park people these types
uh on contacted tribes who are outside
of the system and will never integrate
with it and then the people they
encounter in these suits every so often
metaphors people do have to go out to
maintain the machines they live in I
genuinely believe we are inching towards
living in the Pod and eating the bugs
but it's not how people understand
you're going to come home from work or
whatever it is you have to do you're
gonna your house is going to be akin to
a pod outside with maybe like a plastic
Shield over it just for like nature
protection so you don't die from a bear
attack you're going to lay down in your
pod and then you're gonna go to sleep
and then instantly wake up inside your
Mansion you're gonna walk to your fridge
where you're going to pull out a whole
cheesecake and just shove the whole
thing you're out to be like so good in
the Pod you've got cockroach slime going
into your feeding tube or whatever into
your neck port and you're not going to
care because your brain is being
stimulated in the metaverse it's even
worse Tim uh Alex Jones talks about this
and that you can actually pull this up
because they want to have it when you go
to the metaverse so you can ejaculate 5
000 times a day that's what they think
that's what they think that they would
be doing in the metaverse city
do that now
hold on uh I think if we did a show
exploring a future where people in the
metaverse you would have a portion where
it's like oh that's a sex club and it's
just people standing there going like
yeah ejaculating but hold on hold on
hold on let me ejaculate for so long
people would be wanting dopamine
releases in other ways the idea that
there are not all humans are perpetually
in the state of trying to to achieve
sexual activity says to me that there
would be people who do but most people
would stimulate themselves through
dopamine through the traditional means
meaning guys would go into their own
micro universes where their kings saving
the children from uh from a from a fire
or being they would make themselves
superheroes so they can constantly get
that that masculine satisfaction it's
not I I do not think it's a bunch of
guys being like I'm gonna go and do this
they would guys would do this a lot me
but I would say 99 of their time is
going to be spent in a fictional reality
where they're the superhero doing great
things and everyone loves them for for
having done it in the metaverse you
think that's what men would spend their
time
men are gonna be like you know what
feels the best I gotta tell you yes guys
would love to do the weird creepy you
know fetish stuff but I I'd be willing
to bet more guys would want to be
catching the final touchdown pass at the
Super Bowl 60
000 people cha screaming and they're
just like yeah
and then all the cheerleaders
yeah on the field
this is just kind of to what you're
saying though and this is actually Ian
made a point about it's funny that I'm
referencing Jake and Logan Paul but
you're talking about the sex stuff Jake
Jake Paul is actually I just saw this
clip today he was on a podcast with his
brother and he made a good point he's
like the reason why this Dylan danis
stuff you guys have seen Dylan Daniel
what is it so Dylan danis is supposed to
fight Jake Paul and Jake Paul no no
Logan excuse me fight Logan this is Jake
that said the same and I get him
confused but Dylan danis is fighting
Logan Logan Paul is engaged to a girl
named Nina Agdal she's been in Hollywood
for about 10 years maybe 12 years she
has a picture to him with every A B C D
and e-list celebrity that's ever even
been in Hollywood I mean she probably
has a picture with a thousand different
celebrities Dylan danis has been posting
these pictures like insinuating that
she's sleeping with all these people and
it's super viral I mean he's he's gained
about a million followers since he's
been doing this and Jake his brother was
talking to Logan about why it's so
successful or why Dylan's resonating so
much with people is because men are
scared of women like men are constantly
getting rejected by women they're
constantly addicted to porn they have
impotency problems so it's like the
sexual nature of men we're almost
becoming submissive to women in a weird
way and that's why they like this
because they like seeing a woman get
dunked on I disagree I think that the
majority of men are submissive to women
and that's why when you look at the
dating statistics of Tinder bumblebee or
I'm sorry Bumble whatever uh is that
women choose the top tier of men and men
will go for like the bell curve and male
male perspective for attractiveness is a
standard bell curve and for women it's a
massive Spike towards the high end of
attractiveness and so if you look at how
other primate families do it one
powerful chimp for instance beats the
crap out of their chimps and then gets
all the women
so if we're looking at modern society I
am not surprised to see that there is
you know a majority of men who are
anti-women no are unable to properly uh
woo a woman and then there's a small
percentage of guys who are getting old
women that's like base or instincts the
small percentage of guys that are
getting all the women they don't have to
woo like if you're talking about the
dudes that are like like there's no
wooing it's like if you're one of the
like one of the top guys slide in the
DMS yeah they slide in my DMs they're
like please do it slide my DMs right now
all like these super rip Chad guys are
like I'm insatiable and I want you to
well not at all that's why you never
cyber sex with anybody on the internet
because I guarantee it's a guy
I heard that's what Andrew Tate was
doing yeah he admitted it see and this
is the thing for all the Andrew taperos
I think it's you know some of the stuff
that he you know I I agree with but he
literally there's a video of tape of him
saying I would go on these dumb girls
and I would be talking to the guys and
they would give me all their money and
they asked him like did you feel bad
he's like no oh and I'm like dude
that's disgusting first of all you're
cyber sexing with dudes and then you
don't feel guilty at all that you're
taking all these money under false
pretenses that you're gonna hang out
with them that you're gonna see him or
that you have feelings for him so you
know Andrew Tate I'm not calling him
necessarily a bad guy but that is not a
good thing to do I'd love to see the
chat history on some of those oh they're
disgusting with like what was he typing
to another man you know he was typing
the nastiest stuff because he said it he
said that his brain was better at being
perverted than the girls so you know his
nasty well because guys I mean that's
just the way it is but I I actually am
more interested in talking about uh you
know like Ai and stuff than just what
guys want to do in their free time so
you know anyway a lot of it's connected
well it is yeah a lot of it is connected
Digital Sex man that's
so uh I was talking about this the other
day
the the place that mid journey is at
right now is just insane I posted I
typed in on the show Nancy Pelosi
shaking hands with Vladimir Putin and it
made this photo of that of Putin smiling
and Nancy smiling and there's like
a demonic face on the wall and I'm like
how did it know to do this how did it
know to make it like creepy and evil
looking it just knew and people have
started taking these photos and turning
them into videos through an A through AI
making like three to five second videos
in a year we're gonna be getting five to
ten minute videos and it's going to be
really it's gonna be fantastic quality
video and then in a year or two we're
gonna get the point where you're gonna
have half an hour to hour like videos
with speech like all the components
already exist chat GPT is there you can
create conversations all you have to do
you can do this right now with chat GPT
when they started doing what's called
prompt injection
where to break the rules they said they
get made this huge long text of uh a
long list of texts where it was like
from now on you respond to this you
behave this way you answer these things
and it cracked it it cracked Chet GPT so
that it started communicating like
something else
so I I explored this further and I
started giving it personalities like
from now on you are Donald Trump and it
would start answering my questions as if
it was Trump because of all of Trump's
speech and all of his texts and his
mannerisms are online and in the machine
so that means you could go in a video
game you could create a 3D avatar of
Donald Trump high quality 4K like any
other video game we have today and then
plug chat GPT into it and say hello Mr
President hello how's it going and it'll
actually be a like a facsimile Trump
having a conversation with you you can
do this for any character and it can
happen right now all that needs to
happen right now is the tedious effort
of a game developer being like I'm going
to put plug A and B together
because all the components already exist
when that happens I got to tell you
you're talking about this freaky like I
just want to do weird stuff on the
internet they will do weird stuff in
these games but if you can if if you get
home from working at your burger joint
and you can turn the game on where
you're the football star catching the
touchdown pass to win the Super Bowl
people are going to create characters
who worship them who say everything they
want to say they're going to get their
dopamine release from fake people who
guarantee it to them it is like the
ratney experiment with the electron in
its brain hitting the dopamine button
over and over and over again yeah I do
think that is going to happen but I
think it's going to be a little farther
off than we think because there's a
thing called The Uncanny Valley where
even all of the biggest and I may have
said this on the show before all the
biggest telecommunication companies they
use they spend billions of dollars in
research and development to create
artificial intelligence so when you call
a call center you think you're talking
to a human and human beings when they do
this test Tim we always Pat we always
figure out we're talking to a robot some
people figured out it's just not good
enough it's just not good enough yeah I
know and actually there's a website I
think it's called um what was it called
is it called bot it's it's not called
bot or not but everybody figures out
usually within two minutes on a minute
yeah human or not so
I'm sorry you uh uh you can't figure
this one out that's cool let's see uh oh
it's over the experiment has ended so uh
the issue is
you think you're do you get to talk to
it you you are randomly placed into a
chat with another person okay and you
you are both given a certain amount of
time to respond to each other after a
certain amount of time it asks you was
the person you're talking to a human or
a bot and I don't know what their
results are but I can tell you this I
tricked a whole lot of people you did
and they thought they were talking to a
bot and they were talking to me who is
intentionally manipulating them like I
like it's really obvious to make it seem
like you're a bot and get them to pick
the wrong answer and there was there
were some times where you were doing an
inside job because you were playing a
human acting like a bot that's the point
of it I know you're trying to deceive
the other person to see what they choose
but they're trying to make robots sound
like humans right and so that's a
component of what these things do I
think it'd be harder for a robot to
actually sound like a human than would
be for a human to sound like a robot
humans can can uh create a facsimile of
a robot very easily and robots are
having a hard time right now emulating
humans properly yeah but we are not that
far off yeah I agree so there was a I I
called uh one of my one of the services
that I use everyone has some
subscription service and the person to
answer was like hi thanks for calling
this is customer service how can I help
you and I said human being hey I can
answer your questions just give me a
chance I was like human being
okay well would you like to ask a
question and then I went for the
standard there's one thing you say if
you're tired of talking to the machine
now this was a text prompt like AI chat
language thing but it's just so obvious
about
do you know that there are two words you
can say that will instantly get the
robot to hang up and switch to a human
Donald Trump no operator nope that's
absolutely not I just say an over and
over operator I can say two words
instantly and get it get an operator
What any guess no any guesses two words
no two words I just violently tapped the
zero it's a zero give this a try the
next time you're on with a robot and
many of you will will notice you'll say
human being it'll go if you'd like a
question answered try asking me and
you'll be like representative I can
answer your question oh I tell you what
you say one thing you is it the
tone and that will instantly goes I hear
that you're angry I'll be getting a
representative for you
I can't say that every single system
does this I have been hung up on before
you know and it was just like I'm sorry
I can't help you goodbye and hang out
that's what I usually get but I would
say 99 of the time I was on the phone
with um I think it was United
and they cancel they they switched me
off my first class ticket to a coach
garbage seat on a different flight
without my permission at four in the
morning so I showed up to the wrong gate
confused I'm like what's happening and
they're like we've we've decided
unilaterally to even though you paid
first class to move you to coach on a
different plane to a different city and
I'm like what but your ultimate
destination Remains the Same so it's fun
so I called and I and I get that hi
thanks for calling can I help and I went
you
transferring to a representative
instantly automated customer service
should be illegal that's a life hack I
gotta ask you guys yeah but then just
like like we'll be getting to you in 17
hours yeah on on AI and relationships
when you're in a V because right now I
got a video game called Baldur's Gate
three I just got it and in the game you
can one of your companions you can kind
of hook up with one of your companions
one of them yeah we get to hook up with
all of them
okay hold on hold on let me just add
this
yeah I'm very interested please Baldur's
game is awesome it's this new game that
came out it's like highly rated 10 out
of 10 across the board but because they
wanted to be that everyone you you can
be any Identity or sexuality you want
because it's you every character has to
have a romance path which means
all like if you play as a dude and I'm
like bro I'm just like I'm a rogue
Street pickpocketer that's trying to
make my way through this crazy world and
all these dudes that are coming to help
fight the bad guy keep trying to have
sex with me and I'm like guys stop yeah
the guys are trying to have sex with you
on the show that's right in the game wow
the guys the women the Bears you name it
they throw it at you and I don't know if
you can have multiple partners but
that's not the point the point was you
can't I'm pretty sure yes okay when it
becomes hyper realistic and you're in
like an AI environment and it's a woman
and you're talking to her and she's like
I want to have sex with you tonight is
that cheating on your wife
uh see this is a great hair you're just
gross have you guys have you guys seen
the uh episode of Black Mirror where the
two Bros from college get the new neural
video game and then they start having
sex with each other because like the the
one they play a fighting game and one
guy would choose the Asian martial
artist the other guy who's the Asian
lady so when these two adult black men
go into the video game and everything's
super realistic and they can feel
everything they just for some reason
start having sex instead which I'm
curious as to why the game programmers
put that in the game as a capability but
sure nobody I'm sorry dude if you made a
fighting game and then you're like but
you can also go in there and have sex
I'm pretty sure people would not be
fighting each other in that game but but
my point was just that that's the
premise of the episode that his wife
finds out and it is cheating and so the
agreement they have is that one once per
year he's allowed to go bang his bro and
then she takes off her ring and goes and
has a fling oh well it kind of it makes
you think about Christianity and Judaism
kind of a differential is that and I was
I think someone was talking about this
maybe it's Jordan last night Peterson
but that Chris it wasn't known as Dennis
Prager about Christianity is a lot about
your thoughts and policing your mind and
controlling your thoughts that thinking
of another woman is like is adultery
whereas Judaism is more about your
actions and it doesn't really matter so
much about what you're thinking if you
behave in a certain way then you're
living to God's standards look I'll just
play this and I wonder if AI is a
behavior or if it's just in your mouth
in your mind I will I will say
yes if you are going into a neural link
virtual space to bang other women you're
banging other women what about you it's
like porn cheating because that's kind
of a gray area I've had this public
debate because well it's I'm not going
to sit here in line and say I don't like
to look at a picture of some boobs
sometimes it's a gradient though right
there it's it's a hard line if you got
to figure it out figure it out for
yourself but the general idea is you
should be having relations with your
significant other and if you are if so
the way here's the way I view it if
we're able to go into an AI a matrix and
there was a fake woman that was created
or fake man that was created by the
machine that you knew didn't really
exist in real life
and people would be like oh it's just
like porn it's no different like no no
when you go to a bar and hook up with
someone you know you're not in their
mind like you're just looking for a
fling if you get a fling from you know a
fake person or a person you are still
cheating on your significant other like
you should be having relations with your
with your significant other you should
be but I'll tell you this maybe the
solution for some people is the spouse
and you go in together and have a whole
plethora of weird why is it so much
different for you if it's done in the
metaverse versus done in any other
things well for cheating is it cheating
to them and you can feel it you're
actually doing it oh like in the
Innovative like I don't even I'm super
annoyed with Baldur's Gate for this
because I don't care about having a
romance with some like Devil Woman or
whatever I'm like whatever dude I'm just
trying to like fight this squid guy or
something like that and it's just like I
I'll you in the game you go to camp and
it's like are you sure you want to go to
bed people want to talk to you I'm like
I am not talking to these people because
everybody wants to have sex at the camps
you can you don't this is like sexual
indoctrination
for women
well I I it's I I don't know what the
point is like broken I'm telling you I'm
playing I'm playing a game where I fight
I throw fireballs and summon zombies and
stuff because I just wanna I wanna fight
a dragon you know I mean it's like it's
fun to like level up your guy get
stronger and then you defeat the dragon
the last thing I want to do is go into
the camp I'll tell you what I did though
there's one relationship in that game
that is a must and it's when you rescue
the dog and you play fetch and then you
get the spell of animal speech and then
you walk up normally walk up the dog
he's like you give you pet him and then
he brings you stuff he'll like and then
you could throw the ball and then I got
a potion of animal speech and there's
like hello friend I hope you're doing
well and then I was like I'm sorry about
your master but I'm glad that we're
friends like I'm glad we're friends too
and then you Pat them I'm like that's
the only relationship that matters oh
that's definitely a game to try when I
get back to New York City you guys fun
you meant oh yeah it is pretty good
apparently Starfield not yet well so
it's good it's just there's a lot of
perk wall hey but let's talk about this
because I I did beat it and then I read
the reactions people had to the ending
that I did and it's I think Baldur's
Gate three made a huge mistake with one
of their story lines which allows you to
I would say legitimately beat the game
in five hours or less probably less and
uh I decided to just reload and
purposefully lose to advance the story
and I just think it's it's nothing ever
yeah I tend to play those games just to
experience the game like I don't look
for a victory I just want to do the
quests and explore the you're like me I
like the side quest yeah the whole game
side quests pretty much but you made a
good point like if you're in a video
game and you're like the red square and
it's like the dialogue says I am having
sex with you now yes in the red the blue
square the green square comes up and
then you see like a DOT go back and
forth between the squares that's not
really cheating on your wife right but
if it's a fully looking
no I I think I think I think haptics
would be more akin to like using a toy
I'm talking about if you can plug in the
norlink to your brain and then you feel
the world like you do you go into a bar
and there's a bunch of AI you know
floozies and you're like let's go I'm
like that's Jets cheating well what's
worse because all women that have jobs
have a work husband and you know they'll
might have a boyfriend yeah most women
do you probably do I don't know well I
don't know I don't know what's a work
husband like you know somebody at work
that you're friends with you know
usually a lot of times girls become got
you know friends with a guy and it's
kind of their you've never heard that
term
well that's like a common term uh and
it's really become even more popular
lately and oftentimes it's like what's
worse the emotional cheating of them
becoming best friends or like her having
a one night stand one time never again
or her having a guy that every morning
is giving her coffee and the second tour
that's worse yes
I wouldn't want my wife to bang some
other guy I'd rather have a friend at
work simple question when a guy is angry
that he's friend zoned
the issue is not that they're friends
it's that he wants more so if you have a
significant other who's giving you the
more you ask for and then his friends
the guy who's in the friend zone like
he's in the in the crummier position
people have emotional connections to
lots and lots of people personally I
kind of feel like if you're in a
relationship with someone
I mean my like I don't hang out with
anybody else like me and my girlfriend
literally just do everything together
and it's it's like there's I I don't
call anybody else I have no I don't know
that's just me but that's weird there's
relationships where girls have like best
friends or I'm not a fan of that that
would be like this doesn't work for me
but with for me and my girlfriend if if
like if I'm not working we are going out
together to hang out to like she plays
poker with me we'll be both at the table
and we do everything if we were just
talking about this earlier and I feel
like I need a therapist with my
girlfriend to be able to have this
conversation without going at her like
at each other about it but like women
don't understand or or tend it seems
like they don't quite understand that
guys want to have sex with them that is
in the DNA that men physically if they
become close to a woman friendship-wise
oh right right there's going to be a
desire to have sex and a willingness to
women absolutely understand yeah
listen when they have you as a friend or
they have people that are friend zoned
what that is is keeping the man in a
position to do the things a relation in
a relationship should the relationship
that they're in Fall Apart yeah it's
called orbiters yeah it's like it's like
Orbiter the first time it's like the the
AAA team like he might he's and he's
staying because he's hoping that he gets
called up to the big leagues or he's
back
it's a horrible situation that's why if
a girlfriend zones you stop talking to
her
like if you're interested in a girl I
agree and she friend zones you stop
talking to her but but because she will
she will extract from you even if she's
not intentionally a bad person you are
going to give her attention she is going
to accept it I don't even see it that
way like when I was younger if there was
that's the way it is though no no no no
but that's a bad way to look at it if
there was a woman I was interested in
and she was like you know I'm not
interested you I'd be like I just wanna
let you know I am but clearly there's an
impasse here and I think this is is like
that sounds healthy
that's exactly how I deal with it I'm
like that's good I'd just be like hey
look you're that's cool go do your thing
yeah I'll see you around yeah that's how
I'm out that's the I mean that's the
right thing to do and there's no reason
to be to be women women are allowed to
not like me do you actually that's cool
a long time ago actually I think the
first time you're on the show if you
thought men and women could be friends
you said yeah but that the dynamic
changes it's not like the same kind of
friendship that like a guy would have
yeah I mean like you said I think most
men there is some sort of sexual tension
there Aaron they would sleep with most
the women that they're quote unquote
friends with so it's difficult to
maintain long-term friendships with men
without them wanting to so yeah a lot of
men would would sleep with women they
don't like as well yeah so yeah yeah
do you think it's ethical for guys or
girls that are in relationships to be
chatting uh text chatting with other
people of other Sexes I think it's fine
to have friends of the opposite gender
you know I'm not going all Mike Pence
there but the Pence rule Works what is a
pin's Rule gay conversion therapy works
I love that
so I'm very successful gay conversion
therapy my producer Jimmy I put him
through it and it actually works so go
ahead sir I don't know if it worked for
Jermaine but um Mike Pence he was in the
headlines I don't know this was probably
six years ago now because he won't go to
dinner or do anything with another woman
if his wife's not also present and you
know there's also some people in our
industry and in our field they won't go
to events without their husbands because
they don't want rumors and I totally
understand if I like if I won't like if
I'm on tour or whatever I don't go out
to do anything with only a female ever
at all yep period never ever ever it's
the only way to avoid accusations no I
totally understand the texting is what I
feel like it's Insidious I'm from the
generation before the internet like in
the early 90s late 80s you didn't have
text it was either you you called a girl
on the phone which if I had a girlfriend
I called another girl would be cheating
uh or if I would have to go to her house
to see her and if my girlfriend didn't
know that I was going to a girl's house
to talk to her that'd be cheating so
Phil you're the only one here that I
think is older you're older than me I I
find that it's so casual kids are like
or people that are used to the internet
is like I'm just texting it's just
texting I don't even know I don't even
like the guys all about the person yeah
it's all about the individual I don't
think there's an issue with texting
someone unless you're hiding it from
your significant other and your
significant other doesn't know about
that I think you know a lot of these
conservatives make fun of these dudes
who are like polycules or whatever with
like a big fat woman and they'll be like
you know you see these videos where it's
like a morbidly obese woman and like
five guys behind her and she's like
We're All in This Together and it's like
conservatives make fun of that and I'm
like I really don't think they care like
these dudes live this world they they
live this world it's just
that's it I think some of these guys
might be unhappy and would probably
prefer something better but like it's
the same thing with Chelsea Handler
saying that she wakes up at six in the
morning does drugs and masturbates I'm
just like oh I don't care she's probably
happy I think she'll be unhappy later in
life when she has no family and no one
to take care of her but come on the idea
that she's doing pure dopamine
stimulation right when she wakes up
she's hitting those those those dopamine
centers she probably feels great well
it's funny you say that because one a
guy who I become very good friends with
a guy named Bubba Clem his name is Bubba
the Love Sponge is a radio show and the
reason why he is one of the reasons he's
famous is he let Hulk Hogan bang his
wife and the Hulk Hogan sex tape and the
reason why I bring a Bubba is he's very
masculine guy he's an alpha guy he loves
football this and that I would have
never expected him to be into polyamory
I'm not into it at all but like you said
Tim there are people that are just into
it letting somebody bang their wife
I'm just saying that's just what they
like it's not that I mean I'm not I
don't like that but some people when
he's a normal
self if you allow someone else to sleep
I don't think you're
they want to be a cuckold if if
if you are in a position where your wife
wants to sleep with someone else and you
allow it to happen you are not really
married well my wife and her boyfriend
right now are having a great time I
don't I don't care they're listening it
is clear in law that the word marriage
as a legal concept doesn't matter to
what marriage actually is and the fact
that we are in a world of no fault
divorce means there's quite literally no
contractual marriage at all a real
marriage is when you and another person
actually have that commitment and are
knowingly married like you have a
commitment to each other till death to
us part this idea that people can go to
Vegas and be like we're married now it's
like no you're not dude that's not real
marriage thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time